this video is sponsored by the book
summary service
blinkist being one of the first
philosophers to ever really question the
value of existence
to systematically combine eastern and
western modes of thinking
and to introduce the arts as a serious
philosophical focus
arthur schopenhauer is perhaps one of
the darkest and most comprehensive
philosophers
in western history schopenhauer was born
in 1788 in what is now gdank's poland
but spent the majority of his childhood
in hamburg germany after his family
moved there when he was five
he was born to a wealthy family his
father being a highly successful
international merchant
as a result of this young schopenhauer
would be expected to follow in his
father's footsteps
however from an early age he had no
interest in business
and instead found himself compelled
towards academics
and after going on a trip around europe
with his parents to prepare him for his
merchant career
the greater exposure he would receive to
the pervasive suffering and poverty of
the world
would cause him to become all the more
interested in pursuing the path of
scholarship
and intellectually examining down to its
very core
how the world worked and why or perhaps
more accurately
how and why it appeared to work so
negatively
after eventually going against his
family's ready-made path of
international business
schopenhauer would attend the university
of gottingen in 1809
where in his third semester he would
become more introduced and focused on
philosophy
the following year he would transfer to
the university of berlin
to study under a better philosophy
program led by distinguished philosophy
lecturers of the time
however schopenhauer would soon find
academic philosophy to be unnecessarily
obscure
detached from real concerns of life and
often tethered to theological agendas
all of which he despised eventually
he left the academic intellectual
circuit and spent the following decade
philosophizing and writing on his own
[Music]
by age 30 schopenhauer had published the
two works that would go on to define his
entire career
contain his complete unified
philosophical system from which
he would never deviate and eventually
influence the entire course of western
thinking with
the first groundwork of his philosophy
was established in his dissertation
on the four-fold root of the principle
of sufficient reason
published in 1813 and his entire unified
philosophical system
including his metaphysics epistemology
ethics
aesthetics value judgments and so forth
was laid out in his subsequent
masterwork
the world as will and representation
published in 1819
despite these impressive works going on
to hold major stake in western
philosophy
influencing some of the greatest
thinkers and schools of thought
thereafter
during this time they would go mostly
unnoticed
over the decades following his early
work throughout his 30s and 40s
schopenhauer would spend his time
working to be a lecturer at university
as well as a translator of french to
english prose while continuing to write
on and off
along the side he found very little
success in all of it
his lectures were unpopular his
translations received very little
interest
and his philosophical work remained
mostly overlooked
only by around his 50s did schopenhauer
finally start to receive any notable
recognition
at all and only after publishing a book
of essays in aphorisms in 1851
would he achieve the status of fame
which he would remain in for the rest of
his life
until he died in 1860 at the age of 72.
in terms of schopenhauer's philosophical
system established within his work
it is relevant to note that it leaned
heavily on the work of his predecessor
emmanuel kant
in schopenhauer's mind he was completing
kant's system of transcendental idealism
building off his interpretation of kant
schopenhauer essentially suggested that
the world as we know and experience it
is exclusively a representation created
by our mind
through our senses and forms of
cognition
consequently we cannot access the true
nature of external objects
outside our mental phenomenological
experience of them
deviating from kant however schopenhauer
would go on to argue that not only can
we not know nor
access the varying objects of the world
as they really are
outside of our conscious experience but
there is in fact no plurality of objects
beyond our experience at all
rather beyond our experience is
according to schopenhauer
a singular unified oneness of reality a
sort of essence or force that drives
existence
that is beyond time beyond space and
beyond
all objectification schopenhauer would
go on to explore and define this force
by referencing and probing into the
experience of living within the body
suggesting that this is the only thing
in the world that we have access to
that is not solely a mental
representation of an object
but is also a first-hand subjective
experience
from within it from here schopenhauer
would suggest that what is found from
within
at the core of our being is an
unconscious restless
striving force towards survival
nourishment
and reproduction he would term this
force the will to live
essentially this would lead him to the
conclusion that reality is made up of
two sides
one side being the plurality of things
as they are represented to a conscious
apparatus and the other side being the
singular unified force of the will
hence the name of his masterwork the
world as will
and representation it is worth noting
that the term will can perhaps be
misleading and that it might seem to
imply an intention or human-like
conscious motivation
but the will for schopenhauer is a blind
unconscious striving with no goal or
purpose
other than to keep itself going for the
sake of keeping itself going
all of the material world operates by
and through this will
moving striving consuming and violently
expressing itself
in order to sustain itself
schopenhauer's work was largely a
response to kant and the western
philosophical tradition
but his work also contains distinct
notes of hinduism and buddhism
his conclusion of the nature of reality
is strikingly similar to that of both
and his qualitative assessment of
reality's negative relationship
with the conscious self mirrors ideas
central to buddhism
this made schopenhauer one of the first
philosophers to ever really combine
eastern and western thinking
in such a systematically comprehensive
way especially similar to buddhism
schopenhauer would top off his
philosophical medley with a layer of
dark
unwavering pessimism unless suffering is
the direct and immediate object of life
our existence must entirely fail of its
aim it is absurd to look upon the
enormous amount of pain that abounds
everywhere in the world
and originates in needs and necessities
inseparable from life itself
as serving no purpose at all and the
result of mere chance
each separate misfortune as it comes
seems no doubt to be something
exceptional
but misfortune in general is the rule
schopenhauer wrote as a qualitative
assessment of the nature of reality
he would describe the will to live as a
sort of malevolent force
that we as individual selves become
victims of
in its process of continuation deceived
by our own mind and body
to go against our fundamental interests
and yearnings
in order to carry it out since the will
has no aim or purpose
other than its perpetual continuation
then the will can never be satisfied
and since we are expressions of it
neither can we
thus we are driven to consume beings
things ideas
goals circumstances and all the rest
constantly hoping we will feel a
satisfaction or happiness as a result
while constantly being left in the wake
of each achievement
unsatisfied human life must be some kind
of mistake
the truth of this will be sufficiently
obvious if we only remember that man is
a compound of needs and necessities
hard to satisfy and that even when they
are satisfied
all he obtains is a state of
painlessness where nothing remains to
him
but abandonment to boredom schopenhauer
wrote
as the best possible ways of sort of
escaping and dealing with this
schopenhauer would put forth two primary
methods
one engaging in arts and philosophy and
two
the practicing of asceticism
traditionally being the deprivation of
nearly all desire
self-indulgence and everything past the
bare minimum
in this latter method schopenhauer felt
that by denying the will from being fed
so to speak one would turn the will
against itself and overcome it
however he also recognized the sheer
difficulty of this for the majority of
people
and suggested the average person should
simply make their best efforts towards
letting go of ideals of happiness and
pleasure
and rather focus on the minimization of
pain
happiness in life for schopenhauer is
not a matter of joys
and pleasures but rather the reduction
and freedom from
pain as much as possible the safest way
of not being very miserable
is to not expect to be very happy he
wrote
alternatively engaging in arts and
philosophy
in schopenhauer's mind served as another
more accessible method
he felt that good art could provide a
source of clarity into the nature and
problems of being
without any of the illusion or drapery
and while engaging in this sort of art
one would have a transcendent-like
experience that provides a relief and
comfort from existence
as a result of this concept schopenhauer
would end up being one of the first
thinkers to ever really introduce
philosophical significance to the arts
and would eventually become known by
many as the artist's philosopher
[Music]
of course throughout his work in general
schopenhauer makes large
often unprovable and unknowable claims
about the nature of reality
and the value of existing within it some
of which is validly constructed and
worth considering
but some of which is likely not
ultimately
any attempt to define and assess the
side of reality beyond logic and reason
through systematic logic and reason is
perhaps paradoxical in a way that is
beyond repair
what precisely is the will where does it
come from
where does it end and how can we know or
prove it
and in terms of schopenhauer's
suggestion that one should turn against
the will
through an ascetic process of
self-denial if all of life operates
through the will
to turn against it would seem to merely
be the will turning against the will
for reasons that favor it and there can
be no turning against the will
if the will is doing the turning
alternatively considering the view of
friedrich nietzsche
a philosopher who notably followed in
schopenhauer's footsteps
the endless cycle of desire and
dissatisfaction caused by the will
is actually a good thing that we can use
as fuel towards the process of
self-overcoming
and growth which we can then obtain
life's meaning from
of course this is the more pleasant of
the two interpretations
but it isn't clear which is more apt and
or accurate
if either ultimately schopenhauer is
another surprising yet seemingly common
story
where a highly important thinker artist
or writer
barely caught any recognition in their
life if at all
only to die and end up with their name
in nearly every history book on the
subject
one trait these stories do all seem to
have in common though
is a refusal to stop a refusal to budge
from pursuing and defending the world as
one sees it
schopenhauer never deviated from the
philosophical system he created in his
twenties
and never stops confidently working to
build upon it and reinforce it
throughout his life
despite the world seeming to suggest to
him he should do otherwise
and yet now it is hugely significant to
the world that he did exactly what he
did
for some his work might be bleak and
disconcerting but for others
his work like all great works of dark
melancholic honesty
is comforting relieving and legitimizing
it reminds us that we are not crazy and
our sadness and suffering are not
unfounded
even when they may feel like it we are
merely put in a crazy
sad violent reality with the mind and
body
that are often all in conspiracy against
us
because of this and many other reasons
unmentioned his work would go on to
influence artists like richard wagner
and gustav mahler writers like marcel
proust
leo tolstoy and samuel beckett and
thinkers like friedrich nietzsche
sigmund freud and ludwig wickenstein as
well as many others
ultimately influencing the course of
modern thinking forever
having been one of the first to properly
and philosophically bring the value of
life
and the possibility of meaning into
question schopenhauer helped locate the
early budding problem of the growing
agnostic world
that philosophy would need to address
with humanity seemingly suspending
further out into a void of meaning
his unyielding and fearless
confrontation with the nature of
existence
including all its horrors and miseries
revealed an opening of new possibilities
towards finding answers from within
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
andy age 22 sits on the subway reading
he is currently about a third of the way
through the book until the end of time
by brian greene so far it's a very good
book
but it's starting to veer off somewhat
unexpectedly from theoretical physics
into more soft sciences more interested
in the hard sciences
and he loses some degree of interest
having already read 4 out of 11 chapters
though
he is compelled to keep reading a couple
weeks later
after finishing the book it never really
comes back around to what he was hoping
for
months go by and andy finds that he's
forgotten most of what was contained in
the book
he often has this problem even with many
of his favorites
he sometimes has to reread books
spending a lot of additional time trying
to extract the key points again
and refresh himself the whole process of
trying to find good books he's
interested in
reading them hoping he's right returning
to them later to refresh
slowly draws down on andy's reading
habits
only in his later adult years does he
really start reading consistently again
now in his mid-60s he is reading a book
about a theory in quantum mechanics
known as the many worlds interpretation
which essentially suggests that there
are near infinite other worlds that
exist in parallel to each other
where outcomes of quantum measurements
disperse explaining the randomness
in physics impossible for andy to ever
know
this theory is in fact true and at this
exact moment
in perfect irony in another world
another andy
is listening to an audiobook called
fooled by randomness
which is about the influence of luck on
the economy and life
in this particular world consumer
technology has advanced differently
and when andy was around 22 he was
introduced to a website and smartphone
app
that condenses thousands of non-fiction
books into around 15-minute summaries
providing their main ideas and key
takeaways it also provides complete
audio books and summaries of
podcasts and he is currently using the
audiobook feature
to listen to the complete version of
fooled by randomness
after having listened to the book
summary breakdown in the same amount of
time of his life
using this app andy has explored
thousands of books
authors and a huge range of new topics
outside his immediate interests
he has maintained a consistent and broad
lifelong reading habit
and because of this he has also
discovered a passion for media
which changed the entire course of his
career the app
is of course blinkist and in this world
it also exists and in this world the
first 100 people to use the link in the
description
will receive one free week of unlimited
access as well as
five percent off of full membership the
free seven day trial can be canceled at
any time
within the trial period and of course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]
you